hey everyone its ears red sterner
saurian calm and in this video I'm going
to be going over how to mix insulin what
I'm going to do for you is that I'm
going to actually show you how to draw
up insulin whenever you're mixing it but
first let me go over the most important
concepts that you need to know whenever
performing this nursing skill so what is
the purpose of mixing insulin well the
purpose is is that it helps prevent from
having to give the patient two
injections because a lot of times
physicians will order two different
types of insulin and you can just mix
them in the syringe and give them one
injection so it is better for the
patient now in this video what I want to
be going over are the most commonly
ordered influence that you mix which
generally are in pH which is an
intermediate insulin and regular insulin
which is a short-acting insulin now
before we get started let's go over
these key concepts that you need to
remember number one never mix
lantus which is a long-acting insulin
with any other type of insulin it's to
go all by itself so you will never mix
it with anything number two after
drawing up the insulin into your syringe
administer the dose within 5 to 15
minutes because regular insulin binds to
mph and it will decrease its action
number three before administering
insulin always check the patient for
signs and symptoms of hypoglycemia so
you want to look at the patient you want
to ask them how they're feeling because
typical signs and symptoms of
hypoglycemia is that the patient's
sweaty clammy tachycardic confused and a
lot of times patients will know they'll
say my blood sugar feels low can you
check it because they know their body a
lot better than we do and the reason you
want to check their blood sugar ask them
assess them for signs of hypoglycemia
before you give insulin because the way
that insulin works is that it will take
the sugar that's in the body and
transport it into the cell so to deplete
the system of glucose so if you're
giving them more when it's already
depleted you're going to cause some
really bad problems and then check their
glut their glucose
hitting on your Hospital guidelines
whatever their glucometer readings and
whatever is considered hypo and hyper
glycaemia check for that but generally
anything less than seventy and if that
happens what you would want to do is
that you want to hold that dose and
notify the doctor immediately and ask
what the further orders would be another
important concept if you don't get
anything out of this whole video with
how to mix insulin this is important
okay how you draw up the insulin you're
going to have a cloudy solution which is
your mph to the intermediate and you're
going to have a clear solution which is
the regular acting insulin so whenever
you look at your house that's what it's
going to look like now you're going to
draw up in this order clear to cloudy
the clear again is regular insulin and
the cloudy is NPH the intermediate
acting insulin now to help you remember
this because a lot of people get this
confused try to remember the pneumonic
or in register nurse are for regular and
in for mph so that's how you're going to
drawl up why do you do this what's the
purpose of drawing it up like this well
it prevents contaminating the cloudy
insulin which is an intermediate insulin
with clear insulin which is the regular
insulin now if that happened it would
decrease it would affect the action of
how that NPH insulin would work so you
don't want to contaminate the cloudy
with the clear so that's why we draw it
up that way now I'm going to show you
how to actually mix insulin now this is
just an example always follow your
Hospital protocols your doctor's orders
because procedures and medications do
change over time okay the very first
thing you want to do is you want to
check your physician's order to confirm
how much insulin you're actually getting
and our doctor's order says administer
10 units of humulin R and then 12 units
of humulin n sub-q before breakfast
daily after you confirm that you want to
make sure you have the right medications
so you're going to take your vial and
you're going to look and read what's on
the vial here we have humulin R and you
can tell because it's a clear solution
and then we have our
a vial which is humulin in and you can
tell because it is cloudy and you need
to ask yourself how many how many total
units of insulin am I going to be giving
and ten units of human are and twelve
units of humans so that equals twenty
two units total then you want to make
sure you know the peak time to be
familiar with the peak times of each of
these insulins I have a video of
mnemonics that can help you remember the
peak times of this a card should be
popping up and you can access that so
let's go over it real fast the peak of
humulin R is two hours and the peak of
humulin n is eight hours and this is
when the patient is at most risk for
hypoglycemia and click slice likes to
ask about that so make sure you know
that then next what we're going to do is
we're going to perform hand hygiene
cleaner hands and we're going to put on
some gloves then after we put on our
gloves we are going to take our cloudy
insulin because this is a cloudy
solution it's their mph the intermediate
insulin and we need to mix these
ingredients because they like to settle
so to do that what you're going to do is
you're just going to roll the insulin
gently in between the palms of your
hands and just roll and get it mixed up
because if you don't do this it'll alter
how much mph you're actually drawing up
so you want to make sure the solution is
good mix and never shake it because that
causes air bubbles and that can throw
off how much mph you will actually draw
up okay next what we're going to do is
we're going to take our alcohol prep and
we're going to clean the tops of these
vials make sure we're getting rid of
germs so we're just going to clean for
about five to ten seconds really good
each file and then we're going to go to
the next file and just clean that and
now we are ready to use our syringe so
what we're going to do is you're going
to take the cap off of your syringe and
we are going rimmer remember the
pneumonic
Arion we're going to start with regular
insulin and then go to cloudy so it's
going to go clear
- cloudy regular - mph so we are going
to inject 12 units of air and our human
in insulin so just pull back on your
syringe - 12 units which is there we're
going to inject the 12 units of air into
the vial then we're going to remove our
syringe and we're going to inject 10
units of air into the human tart so
we're going to pull back on the plunger
- 10 units and we're going to do the
same thing but we're not going to remove
our syringe instead we're going to take
the bottle and flip it upside down and
we are going to remove 10 units of
regular insulin and you watch on your
syringe where 10 units is and make sure
it's precise and once you have that 10
units you're going to remove the vial
and then we're going to go to our human
LAN because that was the clear now we're
going to cloudy and we're going to
remove a total of 22 units for the whole
total dose so when to go enter in cage
and we're going to remove a total of 22
units then we'll equal how much we're to
give now after you draw it up if you're
not going to give it immediately what
you want to do to prevent contamination
sticking yourself or sticking someone
else is to do the one hand scoop
technique so just take it and take the
cap and just scoop it up and then you
are ready to go okay so that is how you
mix insulin now be sure to check out my
NCLEX review on diabetes and check out
my other nursing skill videos and thank
you so much for watching and please
consider subscribing to this YouTube
channel